Also jetzt, gut.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist...
Guten Tag, ja, ja.
Mein Name ist Emre Gögtas. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihr persönlicher Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, okay?
Ja, klar.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Mario Dietrich.
Mario Dietrich.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihr Nachname Buch stabilen?
Ja, D, IE, T, R, I, C, H.
C, H, Dietrich, ja.
Ja, genau.
Okay, Herr Dietrich, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin auch 38 Jahre alt.
Verraten Sie mir bitte Ihr Geburtsdatum.
Ja, das ist der 17., 9., 83.
17., 9., 83.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,84 m.
89 und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, so 79 kg ungefähr.
79 kg. Gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Dietrich?
Ich muss jetzt tatsächlich gucken, warte mal, wo bin ich denn?
Er macht die falsche Reihenfolge.
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Ich wohne mit meiner Freundin zusammen, aber verheiratet sind wir nicht.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, nein, nein.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Kommunikationstrainer.
Okay.
Herr Dietrich, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beispiel haben Sie?
Ich habe so schrecklichen Husten und ich habe eigentlich schon lange, ich habe so bekanntermaßen,
so ein überempfindliches Brunchalsystem.
Das haben mir die Ärzte schon viele Jahre gesagt.
Aber jetzt wird es immer schlimmer.
Ich habe so ganz zäh, zäh in Schleim beim Husten.
Und ich habe so ein enge Gefühl in der Brust.
Und das ist ein ganz unangenehmes Gefühl.
Und das macht mir wirklich ein bisschen Angst.
Das rasselt so und das Herz klopft auch ganz doll.
Also ich habe richtig ein bisschen Angstgefühl.
Dann habe ich gedacht, das möchte ich jetzt nicht heute Nacht nochmal erleben.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Das habe gestern Abend angefangen.
Gestern Abend.
Haben Sie schon mal diese Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, solche Beschwerden noch nicht.
Nein. Also wie gesagt, Husten habe ich schon lange.
Aber jetzt hat eine völlig andere Qualität.
Okay. Normalerweise, Sie haben Brunchalempfindlichkeit.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wogegen haben Sie?
Gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser dafür?
Ja, also es gibt natürlich schon auch Sachen,
auf die ich richtig allergisch bin.
Zum Beispiel Nüsse und ganz schlimm auch Trässe.
Da habe ich auch eine Desensibilisierung mitgemacht.
Aber so dieser trockenen Husten,
das habe ich eigentlich schon richtig lange.
Und deswegen habe ich das auch erst gar nicht so ernst genommen.
Aber jetzt so dieses Gefühl,
dass ich sogar keine Luft mehr bekomme.
Ja, das macht mir jetzt doch wirklich Angst.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie Atemnot.
Brauchen Sie, soll ich Ihnen Sauerstoff geben?
Ja, für den Augenblick denke ich mal, geht das noch.
Ich habe den letzten ganzen Tag auch jetzt nichts gehabt.
Okay, dann aber erst mal, ich möchte Ihnen die Monitor einschließen.
Ah ja, das ist sicherlich das Gut.
Und die Blutdruckmessen und Sauerstoffinhalt im Blutmess.
Okay, haben wir das schon gemacht?
Dann fühlen Sie sich jetzt besser?
Ja, allein einfach, dass das passiert,
beruhigt mich schon ein bisschen.
Ja, okay, gut.
Dann können wir mit unserem Gespräch weichzermachen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie enge Gefühl haben.
Sie sind auch seit gestern nach gestern?
Ja, das hat gestern angefangen, ja.
Okay, haben Sie bruschenmerzen?
Ja, Schmerzen eigentlich,
nicht so richtig deutlich mehr,
eher so dieses Gefühl, dass das alles viel zu klein ist.
Okay, haben Sie bemerkt, ob Sie dafür
irgendwelche Auflöser gibt, zum Beispiel,
wenn Sie beim Belastung
die Schmerzen öfter trinken?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Das ist mehr so, ja, vielleicht, wenn ich liege,
dass ich dann das Gefühl habe, ich muss mich wieder aufsetzen.
Und ja, vor zweieinhalb Wochen hatte ich eine Erkältung.
Da habe ich das jetzt irgendwie mit dem Husten alles gar nicht so ernst genommen.
Aber jetzt ist es schon anders.
Ich verstehe.
Vor zwei Wochen haben Sie Erkältung,
ob Sie dafür beim Hausarzt oder eben?
Nein, zurzeit kann man ja gar nicht zum Arzt gehen wegen Corona,
will man ja gar nicht.
Nein, das habe ich so zu Hause ausgerührt.
Okay, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht.
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Und Sie haben auch gesagt, dass Sie Auswurf, schleimige Auswurf haben.
Ja, das ist so ganz eklig, 10.
Okay.
Das kriege ich kaum raus.
Okay, haben Sie Blut im Auswurf gemerkt oder?
Das habe ich nicht gesehen, nein, da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Okay.
Wie war der Konsistenz?
Ja, so ganz zäh.
Das will gar nicht raus.
Verstehe.
Okay.
Und Sie haben auch Herz klopfen?
Ja, gerade wenn das mit einmal wieder so dieses Gefühl ist,
dass ich sogar keine Luft bekomme,
dann fühle ich mich mit einmal so ängstlich
und dann klopft das Herz eben auch doll.
Die Beschwerden treten auch in Ruhe, ja, auf?
Ja, seit gestern.
Vorher war das nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Haben Sie, ja, Sie haben allererge against Nüsse und Gressen.
Haben Sie Kontakt in der letzten Zeit mit Nüsse oder Gressen?
Ich kenne das ja, das meide ich natürlich, diese Sachen.
Also auch, ich glaube auch nicht,
dass ich aus Versehen irgendwas da gegessen habe mit Nüsse.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, das Gewicht ist immer stabil.
Okay.
Und sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein, ich war immer nur zu Hause.
Okay.
Okay, gut.
Dann möchte ich über Ihre Vorgeschichte ein paar Fragen stellen.
Leiden Sie an chronische oder Vorerkrankungen?
Eigentlich nur, eben, was ich gesagt habe, diese Geschichte
mit dem Brunchalsystem, das ist schon 12 Jahre,
dass die Ärzte das immer mal gesagt haben,
das reagiert sehr empfindlich.
Und ich habe dann ja auch mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Und dann dachte ich, damit würde es jetzt vielleicht besser werden.
Aber ja, jetzt geht es irgendwie gar nicht.
Und ansonsten bin ich aber eigentlich ziemlich gesund.
Ich habe oft so Nackenschmerzen,
weil ich halt viel am Computer arbeite.
Und dann habe ich noch so eine Geschichte,
dass ich bei Kälte mit einmal so ein Juckreiz trigg,
an den Händen vor allen Dingen,
dass diese rot werden mit einmal,
jetzt wenn es richtig kalt ist draußen,
und an den Handgelenken,
wenn ich da nicht ganz gut mich einpacke und Handschuhe trage,
dann werden die Hände ganz rot und jucken.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie haben mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Wann war das?
Das ist jetzt drei Jahre her.
Vor drei Jahren.
Warum haben Sie Rauchen aufgehört?
Ja, ich habe ja gemerkt mit dem Husten,
dass das nicht gut ist.
Okay.
Pronschialerkrankungen, wissen Sie,
was ist genau, was genau das ist?
Ich meine, die Namen von Erkrankungen.
Der Arzt sagt immer,
das ist ein übersensibles Pronschialsystem.
Okay.
Okay, und wenn es kalt ist,
dann bekommen Sie Juckreiz und Haltveränderungen.
Ja, aber nur an den Händen.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ach, das ist erst so vor drei, vier Jahren,
nachher hat das angefangen.
Sind Sie dagegen unter Behandlung?
Nein, ich ziehe mir Handschuhe an, wenn es kalt ist.
Aber wenn ich die vergesse, ist das unangenehm.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas in Ihrer Familie
schwerer oder chronischer Erkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich keine chronische Erkrankung.
Meine Mutter hat Nierensteine,
aber das ist ja irgendwie nicht so ein,
das ist ja etwas Akutes eher.
Und mein Vater hat tatsächlich ein Problem.
Der ist alkoholkrank und hat auch einen Entzug versucht,
aber das hat leider überhaupt keinen Effekt gehabt.
Der ist also immer noch sehr schlecht dran.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr Dirndrich, Sie haben keine Fieber und schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, schlafen tue ich tatsächlich nicht gut.
Warum? Darf ich fragen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht jetzt natürlich wegen dieses Husten und so,
das ist es nicht so gut.
Aber vielleicht geht mir auch die Arbeit durch den Kopf,
ich weiß es nicht.
Aber ja, ich schlafe tatsächlich nicht gut.
Okay, ich möchte auch gerne fragen,
wenn Sie legen, dann kriegen Sie Atemnot, ja?
Auch nachts ist das auch so.
Ja, also jetzt diese letzte Nacht hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich muss zwischendurch mal mich aufsetzen und versuchen,
das irgendwie rauszuhausholen.
Verstehe.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise gut.
Sorry, bin wieder da.
Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder was?
Beim Stuhl, ich bin ein bisschen verstopft.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, das ist so in den letzten fünf Jahren,
hat sich das so breit gemacht, ja.
Aber ich nehme da eigentlich wenig Medikamente.
Was für Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme da Lefax, Coutabletten.
Lefax.
Okay.
Und was erlassen? Haben Sie keine Probleme?
Das klappt alles problemlos, ja.
Herr Dietrich, gibt es etwas, was Sie zielig belastet?
Oder?
Ja, jetzt im Augenblick natürlich diese Geschichte,
dass ich so schäbig muss, so kann ich ja nicht arbeiten.
Und ja, dass ich eben so diese schreckliche Luftnot habe
und dass ich mich so schlecht fühle.
Aber sonst belastet mich eigentlich nichts.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Nein, eigentlich nur, weil wir da sind, die sich nicht mehr fassen.
Und wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich die Kluffe nackt.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, habe ich ja gesagt, nicht mehr, ne?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, Entschuldigung.
Sie haben schon gesagt, und vorher, wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Vor zehn Jahren habe ich gut ein Päckchen geraucht, ja.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so gut wie nicht. Also sehr, sehr seltenmal.
Was meinen Sie?
Wie oft trinken Sie?
Wenn ich einmal im Monat ein Glas Wein trinke bei mir,
ein Test oder bei einer Einladung oder so.
Bei mir zu Hause finden Sie keinen Alkohol.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Droge?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay.
Sie sind allergisch gegen Nüchtern und Gräste.
Und sonst haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Nein, sonst ist das eigentlich alles.
Okay, ich möchte auch noch fragen, ob Sie geschwollene Beine haben.
Ne, geschwollene Beine?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, meineseits habe ich die wichtigste Frage gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzuführen?
Nein, Sie haben ja wirklich viel gefragt.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Bin ich eigentlich nur noch gespannt, wie es weitergeht, ja.
Okay, herrlich.
Dass man dagegen machen kann, dass ich wieder besser Luft kriegen kann.
Ja, ich bin wirklich gespannt, wie es weitergeht.
Besser Luft kriegen kann, ja.
Ja, herrlich, haben wir schon die erste Behandlung gemacht.
Wir haben sauerst gegeben, sie pülen sich.
Ein bisschen besser ist schon, ja.
Als nächstes möchten wir die richtige Diagnose stellen.
Deswegen brauchen wir ein paar Untersuchungen.
Erst mal, ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach würde ich Ihnen gerne Blut abnehmen und einen EKG anordnen.
Okay.
Und ich möchte auch Sie zum Röntgen schicken, ja.
Zum Röntgen?
Ja, für die Lungen.
Was wollen Sie röntgen?
Ja, das ist eine bildgebende Untersuchung.
Aber was wollen Sie?
Ich möchte die Lungen untersuchen.
Ja, okay.
Ob Sie irgendwelche Krankheiten im Lungen oder Veränderungen haben.
Ich möchte mit Röntgen kontrollieren, ja.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Und habe ich Blut gesagt?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe ganz gute Wänen, das müsste klappen, ja.
Je nach dem Ergebnis,
vielleicht können wir noch ein paar Untersuchungen brauchen.
Aber dafür sprechen wir noch mal, okay?
Okay, ja, gut.
Dann warte ich jetzt.
Gut, jetzt warten Sie hier, dann ich komme Ihnen wieder gleich.
Danke.
Gut, perfekt.
Gibt es Fragen von den Kollegen?
Keine, wir haben schon alles gefragt.
Keine Frage mehr.
Ich bin mehr nistischer.
Man merkt, er ist ein alter Hase.
Er kennt sich aus mit anderen Mesen.
Hat schon viele gehört.
Ich habe noch ein paar Minuten, aber ich habe noch ein paar Minuten.
Ich brauche ein paar Minuten.
Ja, alles klar.
Okay.
Wenn es keine Fragen gibt,
dann kann ich die Patientenvorstellung anfangen, ja.
Ja, Sekunde.
Ich hatte, wie war das, ob Sie das alle gehört haben.
Ich hatte zwischendurch ein Telefonanruf.
Jetzt muss ich den mal eben schnell absammeln.
Ja, alles klar.
Jetzt kann es losgehen.
Okay, guten Tag Frau Beerzdin.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen,
wenn Sie Zeit haben.
Ja, natürlich.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Es geht um Herr Mario Dietrich.
Er ist 38 Jahre alt.
Er ist Kommunikationstrainer.
Er ist 79 kg, 184 cm groß.
Er klagt über seit gestern.
Er klagt über Spüsten mit Auswurf seit gestern.
Er findet eine brunschale Erkrankung,
aber er weiß nicht genau, was er hat.
Was ist der diagnosticen Namen?
Er ist ein Angenarpektorist.
Er hat auch eine andere Bechwerde.
Er ist eine Autopne.
Er ist gestern Abend.
Er beschreibt die Bechwerde nicht nur bei Belastung,
sondern auch im Ruhr.
Er hat vor zwei Wochen Erkältung gehabt.
Er ist allergisch gegen Nüsse und Gresse.
Er beschreibt die Auswurf mit 10 Schleim.
Er hat keine Blut aufgefahren.
Er hat eine Brunschale Erkrankung.
Er hat nackt Schmerzen.
Er beschreibt auch eine Rehnot-Phenomen.
Er ist kalt und kriegt eine Hautveränderung.
Er ist eine Alkoholkrankheit.
in der vegetative Anamnese, er hat Schlapluppprobleme und Obstipation seit fünf Jahren.
Und er nimmt regelmäßig Medikamente ein, aber bei Bedarf nimmt er Lefax-Pableten gegen
Obstipation und Diplofenac gegen Schmerzen ein. Und er raucht, er habe bis vor drei Jahren
eine Schachtel Zikarette täglich zehn Jahre lang geraucht.
Oh ja.
Und ja, das war es.
Gut, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Diagnose? Was fehlt denn denn?
Okay, ich, nach den bisherigen Angaben, gehe ich von einem Arthmi oder Herzarthmi oder
Unstabileingener Pektoris.
Das wäre differenzial diagnostisch?
Differenzial wird diagnostisch kommen, zum Beispiel ein Pulmoner-Emboli und ein Arthmi-Alfibrillation
oder ein Pynomonie vielleicht im Betracht.
Gut, was machen Sie diagnostisch denn jetzt mit Ihnen?
Ja, diagnostisch. Ich würde gerne diese Patienten erstmal körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie besonders?
Ja, beim körperlichen, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, Oszultation ist sehr wichtig.
Ich höre erstmal die Lunge ab.
Und was erwarten Sie, was Sie da hören?
Ja, der Patient hat übliche bronchkrankheiten wie ein Asthma,
deswegen können wir Strido oder zum Beispiel Hörn oder Raslgeräusche hören.
Und in der Auskultation?
Ja, wenn Sie klopfen.
Perkution?
Perkution können wir hypo-
Hypo-Sonur und Kopfschall.
Und auch körperliche Untersuchungen, ja, das war es.
Wir können die Herz abhören.
Ja, natürlich.
Und danach, ich veranlste eine EKG.
Und im Labor würde ich ihm Blut abnehmen.
Im Blut können wir die Entzündungparameter, Blutbild bestimmen
und die Herzwerte, Troponin, CK, CK, ND.
Und die Pulmoneremboli, DEDIMA, können wir auch kontrollieren.
Und Sie haben Ihnen jetzt schon am Monitor dran, was kontrollieren Sie da?
Im Monitor, Sauerstoff-Sättigung.
Das ist es auch eigentlich schon.
Was machen Sie noch für eine technische Untersuchung?
Apparativ-Untersuchung würde ich die Patienten, der Patienten eine Ultraliografie durchführen
und können wir auch eine CT veranlassen, vielleicht.
Ja, aber Sie wollten, glaube ich, noch etwas anderes machen.
Ein Röntgen?
Ja, natürlich.
Und auch diese Patienten, spyrometri, oder?
Ja, genau.
Also, wenn sich raus wird, dass es nicht das Herz ist, ja.
Wenn das EKG unauffällig ist und wenn der Kardiologische befunden unauffällig ist,
dann müssen wir natürlich auch die Spyrometrie gucken, ne?
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja, wunderbar.
Wenn es sich jetzt bestätigt, dass der tatsächlich einen akuten Astmaschub hat,
was würden Sie dann ihm dann therapeutisch angedeihen lassen?
Therapeutisch können wir die Cortison, inhalation, falsch inhalateur
und geben wir noch Sauerstoff und Salbutamol.
Ja, sehr schön.
Was noch?
Ja, das ist eigentlich schon die Hauptsache, genau.
Gut, ich habe jetzt noch, also ist das wirklich alles ja komplett?
Untersuchen Sie dann Ihren Patienten?
Ja, ich habe jetzt noch drei Prüfastragen.
Und die eine Frage war, ob der Patient erhöhten Blutdruck hat.
Erhöhten Blutdruck, ja, kann sein.
Hat er etwas davon gesagt?
Er hat dafür nicht gesagt.
Er hat es nicht gesagt, genau.
Ja, ja.
Wenn er es gesagt hätte, wenn er über hohen Blutdruck und Medikamente gesprochen hätte,
was wäre dann etwas, wo man hellhörig werden muss?
Worauf muss man dann achten?
Herzinfuzientinspezienz, meine ich?
Ne, dann würde er ja ein Medikament bekommen.
Ah, man betablocker.
Ja, das ist die ACE-Hämmer.
ACE-Hämmer machen offensichtlich trockenen Husten.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich meine, das trifft jetzt für diesen Patienten ja tatsächlich nicht zu.
Aber wenn jetzt in einem anderen Fall das so wäre,
dass der Patient sagt, er nimmt ACE-Hämmer wegen Blutdruck,
dann müsste man sagen, vielleicht ist das die Ursache für ihren chronischen Husten.
Ja, genau.
Genau.
Und dann diese Diagnose, hyperreagibles Bronchialsystem,
ist meine ich tatsächlich eine eigene Diagnose.
Also eigentlich beschreibt das ja nur, dass jemand sensibel reagiert,
sobald er irgendwie eine Besonderheit in ausgesetzt ist,
sei das klimatisch oder eben durch irgendwelche Stoffe in der Umgebung oder Stress.
Gut.
Gut, hier ist die Frage.
Welches die wichtigsten Differenzialdiagnosen sind für das Asthma-Bronchale?
Also gerade jetzt beim Erwachsenen.
Die finanziellen Diagnostik.
Ja, hast du das schon gesagt?
Was habe ich gesagt?
Du hast die vorhin genannt.
Pynomonie pulmerambulin, habe ich gesagt.
Was war deine Hauptdiagnose?
Hauptdiagnose um uns stabileingener Pektoris.
Ja, genau.
Die sagen hier, die wichtigsten Differenzialdiagnose
ist neben die Angina Pektoris und die Lungenambulin.
Genau.
Gut.
Und dann haben Sie noch nachgefragt, nach dem Fachbegriff
für einen Akuten Asthma-Anfall.
Akuten Asthma.
Mir ist nicht bekannt.
Extra Zerbation.
Also das war jetzt hier tatsächlich eine ausdrücklich aufgeführte Prüferfrage.
Gut.
Danke schön.
Ja, also das war wieder mal eine sehr, sehr schöne Analyse
und auch ein sehr guter Bericht.
Ich muss nur nerven.
Ich habe das schon ganz, ganz oft gesagt,
bei allen möglichen Leuten.
Das kommt immer, immer wieder vor.
Wir haben die reine Folge im Deutschen, wenn wir einen Platz bilden.
Ich würde als erstes eine körperliche Untersuchung machen.
Wenn ich aber sage, erstmal...
Erst mal würde ich.
Genau.
Dann muss es umgedreht sein.
Und das macht ihr alle.
Also ich kenne fast niemanden, der das nicht macht.
Es ist tatsächlich aber einer der häufigsten Fehler,
der mir auffällt.
Und das ist so einer, der so ein Signal setzt.
Der zeigt, oh, das ist jemand, der die Sprache nicht komplett beherrscht.
Oder das ist jemand, der es gelernt hat.
Und gönnt doch dieses Vergnügen nicht, dass sie das gleich erkennen.
Sondern du weißt es ja, alle wissen das,
was die Satzstellung dann anders ist.
Und wir Deutschen selber, ich gestehe es,
wir machen es auch ja nicht immer richtig.
Wir auch fangen wir einen Nebensatz an
und beenden ihn als Hauptsatz.
Ja, ich muss jetzt aus dem Zimmer,
weil ich muss zum Telefon.
Nein, weil ich zum Telefon muss.
Wir machen das selber auch.
Ja, aber trotzdem, wenn etwas vorne wegkommt,
dreht sich es um.
Ja, ja.
Und ich glaube, einmal hast du dich auch korrigiert,
weil du es gemerkt hast.
Aber es kam tatsächlich ein paar Mal vor.
Und ja, ich muss ja irgendwas zum Meckern haben, oder?
Alles klar.